quick note i don't want to spend a ton
of time on this but donald trump has
decided to cancel the event that he had
planned for tomorrow trump was going to
do a press conference at mar-a-lago his
florida resort tomorrow january 6 2022
the one-year anniversary of the trump
riots on january 6 2021 uh he has now
canceled that maggie haberman from the
new york times says that quote among
other things several advisers former
formal and informal told trump the press
conference was a mistake
and it was becoming clear he wasn't
likely to get the live tv coverage that
he was hoping for so there's actually
two interpretations of trump's decision
to cancel this one is he realized
there's no way to spin
what happened last january 6th in any
way in any way that would be remotely
advantageous to him that's one
possibility
trump's ego tends to push in the other
direction which is i can always spin
anything to be good for me
so the other interpretation is trump got
word that the major networks were not
going to be carrying that press
conference live and decided it wasn't
going to get the publicity that he
wanted and that really does anger the
guy so that has been cancelled important
donald trump will be appearing at a
rally in the state of arizona not this
saturday but next saturday uh january
15th and he has put out a statement
saying that then
he will offer his thoughts
on what happened on january 6th so he'll
eventually speak about it but rather
than being in front of what was destined
to be a small television audience he
will do it in front of a live audience
on january 15th we'll have more
information about that that may also get
cancelled but the january 6 2022 press
conference trump had planned for
tomorrow at mar-a-lago is canceled make
sure you're following the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
we're going to take a very quick break
and be right back
one of our longtime sponsors is monk
pack giving you 20 off monk packs keto
nut and seed bars which taste just like
your favorite sweet snacks
but without the guilt because they have
only one gram of sugar two to three net
carbs and 150 calories a great snack if
you're doing keto if you're doing low
carb and if you just want a low sugar
snack i love the monk pack nut and seed
bars great balance of sweet and salty
satisfyingly crunchy soft and chewy
because i like these so much i use monk
packs subscription feature sends them
straight to my house on a regular basis
and saves me 10 percent if you don't
love monk pack as much as i do they will
refund you all your money i think
there's a really good chance
monk pack nut and seed bars become your
favorite go-to snack
monk pack is giving you 20 off your
first order go to monkpack.com and enter
the code pacman at checkout